[Music]
stunning new video shows how the world's
most famous shipwreck may soon be lost
forever scientists who took these
pictures say that Titanic is
disappearing they estimate it could be
completely gone within 20 years eaten
away by bacteria marine life and sea
currents Ian Lee takes a look at the
threat the Titanic sails through time
while resting more than two miles below
the North Atlantic the once
indestructible ship is now disappearing
at an alarming rate
the first deep-sea explorers to visit
the site in 15 years
say metal-eating bacteria are causing
history to drift away
captain's bathtub is a favorite image
among Titanic enthusiasts and that's now
gone gone too are the once grand
staterooms and Lounge over five dives in
eight days scientists measured the rate
of decay the destructive bacteria along
with corrosion and currents is consuming
the rusty remains but the intact
porthole glass still offers a window
into the past the ship made its maiden
voyage in 1912 days later it hit an
iceberg killing more than 1500 people
researchers say the Titanic could all
but vanish in a couple of decades
Titanic's returning to nature without
upkeep without maintenance its devolving
back to its natural state just like
anything else so scientists hope when
the Titanic is gone their work helps the
legend live on for CBS this morning
Ian Lee in London we called it a
threaten without upkeep without
maintenance I don't think there should
be upkeep in maintenance no the natural
way of thing is lasted this long and in
some ways you know yeah - every time I
see it there are think of that Celine
Dion song won't break out into now but
it is amazing that it looks the way it
looks after all this time but they
mentioned that the captain's bathtub has
already dissolved away and it makes me
feel small on a good way to know that
it's just all disappearing those
pictures will always be haunting just
amazing